hey guys I am so excited because me and
my sister are heading to the Grand
Canyon and I've never been to the Grand
Canyon before I've always wanted to go
we've talked about going for years ever
since I first moved to California the
Grand Canyon has been on our to-do list
well today is the day before so I've got
to go do some prepping a little bit of
shopping because it's apparently very
very very very very cold at the Grand
Canyon right now and that is something
that we were not expecting probably we
should have checked the weather before
we booked this trip but this is the only
time that we could go so we kind of
crammed all of these things in in
basically two days one thing that I'm
doing right now in preparation for my
trip this is actually really exciting
because I have always been a huge
Michael Kors fan watches purses all of
those camel purses that I have that you
guys have seen me use over the past
years oh Michael Kors most of the
watches that I wore prior to the Apple
watch Michael Kors
and I've been really interested in
testing out their smartwatches so I've
got one right here that I just got I was
so excited that I set it up and I didn't
even film it and I'm thinking shoot I
should have showed you guys the setup
process because it was super simple I
really never tried any of the Android
watches before and what better way to do
it then celebrating my first Android
watch then with a Michael Kors watch but
it's a little bit big so I'm gonna head
down to the nearest Michael Kors store
to get this thing sized before I head
off on my trip ok google' where's the
nearest Michael Kors store I gotta go
get this thing sized this is when one of
the new rose gold Sophie watches and I'm
a huge rose gold fan as you guys know
from all of my videos plus this
beautiful matching case oh my goodness
one of the other things that I do like
is you can also customize it using
Instagram or Facebook or any of the
photos that you already have or your
friends send you you can set them as
your watch faces a common misconception
with smart watches especially Android
ones is it's not gonna work with your
iPhone well that's not true this is the
Android wear app and this allows you to
connect to your watch so you use this to
set it up customize watch faces you can
also customize all the watch faces and
stuff on your watch as well you don't
need your phone so in here I'm going to
go to my Instagram it's either me and
Rowe or Matty man gives you some digital
or analog yes set it as my background
and there he is little Matty oh my watch
okay Google set an alarm for 5:00 a.m.
tomorrow morning
that's not fun I know I could probably
size this myself but I'm not because I'm
also wanting dinner and there's dinner
right next to the Michael Kors door I
love it this is a little touch screen to
use when a fish let's go get this thing
sized
feed it down to third Street to Michael
Kors
to get this watch side
okay we're inside and she just took my
watch and she's sizing it up for me so
maybe I'll do a little bit of shopping
first while I wait rose gold rose gold
oh wow
[Music]
shoot what do you think I have very tiny
ribs it's all sized up and ready okay
Google what time is my alarm set for
tomorrow morning
[Music]
oh my gosh this is too early no I can't
do that right now guys I don't know no I
don't want to wake up yeah
[Music]
oh what a mess well I'm definitely not
awake that's for sure
well I'm gonna pack and stop blogging so
that I can actually be ready on time so
Jenna won't yell at me see you soon
[Music]
sorry I'm late all right you expected it
yeah okay it is what time is it oh my
gosh it doesn't matter 28 28 okay I'll
go get the coffee
hurry hurry and also we can't what's
everything we gotta spinach wraps your
sandwich and egg by egg whites
[Music]
all right oh wait be there in seven and
a half hours - okay Google get
directions to the Grand Canyon
[Music]
it's 9:45 Jenna hasn't got pulled over
yet so that's really a plus thanks Jen
well we have six hours six hours still
Wow
really Wow I've already had a year
Vermont a a coffee half a bottle of
water and it's not even 10:00 a.m. and I
haven't peed in a long time so it's
probably gonna be wow I don't know I'm
good so far give it ten
it's all your blood now what I'm
thinking about it oh no
[Music]
10:24 how many more miles until you run
out of gas
137 but we have like 350 to our
destination
so we're also coming upon something here
that may look like a dust storm no
that's not a cloud it's all look at that
yeah over there I'm looking at the road
to see this is a dust storm
this is developing it's developing it's
windy Jenna let us know that it's windy
everybody
still haven't peed yet look at that
different movie Trevor's
it's about how do I like MIT it's about
a big worm a big worm and they go into
the ground and they come did you ever
see the movie The Hills Have Eyes no you
haven't seen tremors don't talk to me
that's how they get you
they're under the ground
is this such a bouncy ride like my
cameras bouncing or hope look at the
dust eyes your brain so well I didn't
sleep last night
although we survived the day I brought
the first-aid kit we have so many snacks
and so many things of water and like a
blanket that if we have to survive it
probably survive for at least five hours
[Music]
first up the first peek
something ish I don't want to see well
look at that huge sign it says gasps
this looks like the the trio ASIS but we
saw not return it does sounds like in
the pit southward County route 66
oh there's full mingles over there and
like a pond we need to investigate this
area after we paid it's a lot colder
than I thought it was gonna be
Wow chilly there's a dog standing right
in the middle of a parking lot
[Music]
[Applause]
snacks suitcases the time is 11:30 6:00
we've made a first stop look at all the
snacks do you want a soda even the music
is excellent here see we need a gallon
here really I'm shook look at this this
one shake you I like it you should get
one for the car
there's more stuff over here yellow
sweatshirt hey there's a sale on yellow
sweatshirts wine to go John I know I'm
driving but I've been really into ginger
ale lately usually I'd use in the car
cuz I get carsick but I'm feeling pretty
good right now I think I'm gonna get a
snack too I'm gettin a Nutter Butter I
just gotta go see this pond over here
man it is super chilly I can't believe
it I met some random viewers is at this
gas station so hello girls it was lovely
to meet you now I'm going to investigate
this pond look at this this is so cool
yeah I think that's it
oh gosh Wow okay
[Music]
snow it's pretty cold what's the
temperature Jen 34 and dropping I'm
getting very tired I'm not even driving
like not to be anything excessive eating
sound like man so we are a hundred and
some miles from the Grand Canyon
[Music]
oh there's free coffee here where are we
I'm not sure there's a lot of stuff
going on it's really cool old cars
little vintage looks
[Music]
that's I'm definitely set free coffee I
think it might have just been like a
sign but not actually a sign that it's
true now what do we do
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta go to the next one this is the
one it is very chilly historic route 60
I'm een I would never this open this is
not open
okay well the sores not open
[Music]
I guess let's get in the car
we now officially have snow there's snow
we have snow there's snow it's official
all I've got does that I have a feature
of my car if I pressed it over it will
put it just no gravel is some other
modes two days few people we got a lot
of stuff go girl Jenna drove the whole
way
glorious what was the total hours Jen
like eight hours or so
yeah around eight hours that's with
three stops you drove the whole time
yeah I got real sleep we just took naps
and I ran ahead to dinner and then we're
gonna go to bed okay Google what is the
weather in the Grand Canyon
Oh 19 degrees tomorrow of tomorrow Aloha
3 today 107 we're gonna get dinner now
so let's go let's go eat I just brushed
my hair so it looks really fantastic if
you were wondering why do I look like a
mess I'm tired
oh no come here little boy I think I'll
take the small guys at dinner we've
decided that we're gonna have dinner
here at our they're playing Foo Fighters
they've got some of my well cameras have
some my favorite games has been not a
good game selection would they have
stacker
[Music]
beautiful so I'm prepping the gear very
sure on your feet they're gross I could
wear this over top of these over top of
yoga pants so thought these fleece pants
it's very cold out guys like it's so
super cold please
can we try these on to see people
filming don't tell me what I can and
cannot do you boy you can't go down on
you oh boy this is so tight this fits
because I got these extra pay so that
three pairs of pants on I got this
jacket in Iceland there you go and then
with this over top of my head so really
we're ready for tomorrow the meal will
adventure I can't hear anything
I've so many live got so many layers you
see on the meals tomorrow you ready yes
I'm breathing heavy
[Music]